[Music]
let's go to denver we've got amber in
denver colorado hey amber how are you
hi john and christy um i am calling
because i
am struggling with my marriage um what's
up i've been married for
i i've been married for two and a half
years um it's actually my second
marriage
um and when i married my husband i had a
long list of
um things that he needed to check off um
before i decided to get married and he
checked off a lot of those boxes
and uh hold on hold on hold on hold on
before you go any further i just humor
me
what are some of the things on your on
your on your magical
mythical uh fantasy list um
kind uh let's see what reliable
um keep going those are those are the
easy ones
give us the ones that are going to make
me roll my eyes uh um
sturdy stable um
sturdy really sturdy like i'm looking at
a guy in the lobby
that's got about 150 pounds of just raw
beef on him
he's ripped i mean i i just think
somebody's um
that kind of passionate and easy easy
going
is the right way to put it passionate
and easy going okay
continue no no not not passionate not
passionate easy going
okay um compassionate nice you know
yeah um and
he he i think for him his checklist was
more like
um you know stable good with money has
comes from a good family
type thing and we're kind of coming to
this pivotal moment in our relationship
where we
are realizing that we don't have that we
never had like the love spark
and i'm really struggling trying to
figure out if
if that's actually an unnecessary thing
to have
so a yes you should you should man
you're saying all the things
if this feels like a like uh i'm not
even gonna go there
you're saying all the things um so yes
you have to love the person that you're
married to that's that's a
one of the cornerstones of marriage is i
love the person
um i often wince
when somebody says we're coming to this
apex moment especially when it's two and
a half years in
um that feels like you have set yourself
up for
a determined outcome that you want and
you want to blame it on a moment
right so why'd you marry this guy
if he's sturdy and compassionate and
kind and lovely
yeah and i promise that he wanted you
for more than you were good with money
yeah right right my first marriage was
pretty
tumultuous it was a lot of um there was
a lot of passion and love but it
ended badly yep um there was infidelity
and addiction and
so i knew that i guess i feel like i
didn't trust that anymore and i wanted
something a little bit more stable and
reliable okay
and i i i'm just like i guess i'm
struggling because i always believed i
could just cool we could just cultivate
something that was
worth it but it feels a little bit more
like an arranged marriage type situation
and and it's been a few years since i
looked at that
it's been a few years since i looked at
the data but arrange marriages over time
when they decide they're going to put
the work in they love each other the
data on that suggests that they
last a long long time yeah and so what
i'll tell you is you've got a lot more
choice in this than you're allowing
yourself
um christy you're i can feel you just
moving
like almost uh
well no i can feel it from you well when
well when you were saying the checklist
amber
when you were saying the checklist of
what you wanted in a spouse
i already knew what your previous
relationship was because your checklist
was pretty consistent
and typically when someone is passionate
i'm looking for these things kind
compassionate stable i'm like well she's
been somewhere where she didn't get that
because otherwise she wouldn't be so
definitive i need these things like
you've been hurt you've been wounded
uh i i think there's an element of this
and john i actually want to throw it
back to you on this on this aspect of
i think people view marriage differently
as a believer
as a child of divorced parents
i'm like no i'm in it i'm in it unless
i'm in it but that's how i view marriage
everyone doesn't view marriage like that
everyone doesn't view marriage depending
on your faith
and so i think how you view marriage
greatly
i would imagine affects how you make
decisions
because i hear this as hard make the
choice to love each other
work at it stick with it and and turn it
into what you want it to be
but everyone doesn't see it like that
and well you just feel like you need to
you just said something that is counter
cultural yet
scientifically accurate which is make
the choice to love
esther perel is the one um who
first put me on to this which is
it used to be historically that we put
um we got our security and our stability
from our institutions right from our
small villages from our churches from
our local schools
and as those institutions have shifted
and changed over time
we've looked at a our marriage partner
and said you are
everything your stability you're my love
you're my romantic you're my passion so
here's the thing
you've got stability you've got kindness
you've got a person of character
desire is something that you practice it
is something you say
i'm gonna be about and he's gonna be
about it too
and y'all are gonna have the adventure
of a lifetime
practicing desire you've got the
stability and the safety
now you decide we're not this marriage
is not going to end
we're going to practice desire and we're
going to be all in and you're going to
look up in six months and you're going
to be so in love with this dude that
your house is on fire that's good
that's good do you think disney movies
have ruined us i think they have they
destroyed everything
this is the ramsay show